now Jill in Phoenix is up
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Jill how
are you I'm doing well thank you so much
for taking my call sure how can I help
so really quickly I'm just trying to
figure out which debt to pay off first
I guess just a little bit of background
we were on the path to being debt-free
we only had our house and my husband
student loan payment then came a car
accident in 2016 somebody else's fault
that the way my vehicle that settlement
money that I got I used to get a car
from my husband a newer car and
completely paid it off in cash so we
were still without without a car payment
because I went back to driving my old
pickup so now Steph forward to March of
this year somebody runs into my husband
and tolls the cars that we had just
bought two years prior so now we have in
car payments you were driving your old
pickup that's paid for you got an
insurance check when you saw when you
got hit why did you go into debt well my
my old pickup is is pretty much running
on on fumes so you use the Rick as an
excuse to rationalize and go buy cars
you couldn't afford yeah I guess you
could set it that way no okay because
you had the money I mean they give you a
check when you have a rack right right
okay so the well I guess I should back
that so I used the property damage to
pay for my husband's car so I still have
the settlement the the medical
settlement that I got and I'm using that
to pay for my vehicle so that's pretty
much your medical settlement is a
monthly settlement no it was paid it was
paid for outright no I thought you have
some in the bank yes I do how much is in
the bank right now
or that I there's about 14,000 how much
is in the bank total not counting your
emergency fund in the bank total were
sitting at about 27 and how much do you
owe on your cars for the cars were
looking at about she's gonna hurt to say
out loud what we're looking at about 80
oh my lord
y'all lost your minds didn't you yeah I
think so now that I've actually said it
out loud yeah and I were home wait for
household into them we made we get about
120 years okay
you have to sell the cars this is
insanity it's insanity you have almost a
year's income tied up in cars so we we
are still waiting on on the settlement
from my husband's car accident so but I
mean it took almost a year for mine to
be process so my plan was to use the
money that we get back for his medical
gold what you're not I'm not sure yeah
and how much student loan debt there
were right now we're sitting at eighty
nine hundred listen you know okay so
here's the thing even if the cars were
paid for in cash eighty thousand dollars
tied up in things that are going down in
value when you make a hundred and twenty
is mathematical insanity you have bought
cars that are way over in the stupid
zone there are very nice cars but I
don't know which one of these is a big
one but the you know you do not a real
good rule of thumb if you ever want to
build wealth is to not have more than
half your annual income invested in
things with motors and wheels
and you're substantially up for that so
if it's anything I tried talking the
husband into getting a different vehicle
but that didn't work out well I listen
you're not stupid people but you've done
some very stupid things here
I'm not stupid people but I've done some
stupid things in my life and you you
know you call me so you ask for it you
know I'm gonna love you enough to tell
you the truth kiddo so I want you to win
it doesn't affect me my life is going to
go on but I want you to win and you're
not gonna win with these cars you guys
are gonna this was very what has
happened here is the emotions associated
with two very bad car accidents and the
physical drain exasperating those
emotions making it worse because of the
injuries associated with it how it just
upsets your psyche and it upsets your
life when you go through two very
violent transactions physically violent
it affects you and in that moment of
weakness you guys walked off into the
land of stupid and you've really hurt
yourself there's been another car wreck
now and it's sitting in your driveway
with payments on it this is the third
car wreck okay so you got to get rid of
these kiddo you're just not gonna win
doing this it's just a stupid car I mean
I like cars I'm a car guy but this is
you just can't win this way now you do
whatever you want to do but I've been
doing this 30 years and I'm here to show
you how to have a good life with your
money how to build wealth with your
money and how to drive whatever you want
to drive eventually with your money but
um you guys have made some serious
mistakes and they have four wheels on so
you do whatever you want to do kiddo but
that's what I would do if I were in your
shoes I'd sell both of them I get in
expensive paid for cars that I can pay
cash for I'll use the 27,000 and the
the money that's coming in immediately
clear up the student loans and pay cash
for cars and get no get cars never again
all your vehicles added up and things
with wheels and motors added up should
never be more than half your annual
income with very very rare exceptions
and you should always pay cash hey I
hope that helps I don't know if you're
going to do it or not but that's what
you should do
thanks for the call